The bulk of canvas interaction that GRITS uses, is through rendering images to
the canvas. In order to draw an image to the canvas, we first have to load it.
In order to load an image, we need to create a new image object, which in
Javascript, is comprised of three steps. Number 1, is we need to declare the
image object. Number 2, is we need to define its onload function. Then number 3
we need to set the image.source attribute. It's worth noting that as soon as the
source property if this image is set through a value Javascript will kick off
onload function. Because of this, we need to specify the callback function first
before setting the source attribute. Otherwise the image will load the data and
we won't get a callback received.
Now let's take a look at this code. Here is the url of the image that we'd like
you to load. What we want you to do is create a new image object, following the
steps we just mentioned, and set the onload function and source properties for
that image described in the code. Make sure that your onload function is
assigned to this onImageLoad down here, which will actually print out some nice
little message to the console log, letting you know that things have loaded
properly. If you're confused about whether or not your image is loading, don't
forget to check out Chrome's developer tools on the network tab, which will list
whether or not the image has been loaded, and how long it took to do it.